welcome to our press conference
following the informal eoco dinner
and the western balkan summit
the president of the european council is
joined here by the president of the
european commission and by the president
by the prime minister of slovenia as as
host we're also having a journalist
following us remotely so
uh we'll take we'll take some questions
there we have translation in french
english and slovenian mind you
and i give the floor now to the
president of the european council
[Music]
[Music]
very important point the fundamental
values rule of law fight against
corruption this is the dna of the
european project this is also an
important topic among the 27 member
states on a regular basis we have
discussions we have political debates on
those topics in order to see how we can
achieve more progress in order to to to
make sure that we all follow that we all
respect
those fundamental principles this one
first point and this is key because this
also uh the choice that we want for the
european member states but also the
choice that the governments in those
countries the western balkans the one
for their societies is the first point a
certain point this is key this is
paramount this is the link between the
the reforms that are needed and we would
like to encourage this was our common
message the reforms in those countries
and the investments and here the
commission took very fundamental
decisions by providing a lot of money an
unprecedented amount of money in order
to connect the western balkans on the eu
priorities in order also to facilitate
to encourage the regional cooperation in
this region which is also key for the
future and you know what are our common
priorities the green deal but also the
digital agenda and we hope that
those investments will play an important
role also in order to to make the
european presence the eu's presence more
visible more tangible for the people in
those countries so they can feel they
can see what are the concrete benefits
coming from this partnership this
strange partnership with the eu
[Music]
thank you so much
first of all let me also congratulate
prime minister ayanza for this
successful summit and thank you very
much for the outstanding organization
and hospitality we've had here
so
let me reflect on the western balkan
summit first
the commission's message is very clear
first of all the western balkan is part
of the same europe as the european union
we share the same history
we share the same interests the same
value values and i'm deeply convinced
also the same destiny
and the european union is not complete
without the western balkan so
my commission will continue to do its
utmost to advance the enlargement
process
and the region's eu integration
we want the western balkan in the
european union there cannot be any doubt
that our goal is enlargement
and my second message today was that the
economic and investment plan is at the
core
of our engagement with the region
indeed with 9 billion euros put on the
table in grants
we can leverage up to 30 billion euros
for the region
the economic and investment plan is
accompanied by the berlin process
and it is crucial
for the development and the deeper
integration
of the common regional market
the market integration will be as
beneficial to the western balkan as the
single market is to the european union
therefore our focus is now on developing
this
common regional market
last week i was traveling to the six
western balkan countries and
besides the discussions on
the topics i was just mentioning
i also felt people's impatience
and partly their frustration over the
length of the process to join the
european union
and i understand that
so what is the way forward based on this
on the issues of reform
it is clear that
our partners in the western balkan are
undertaking important reforms
i'm not saying that they are there yet
but there is obvious a lot of progress
visible if you look over time a lot has
changed to the better and now it is
important to stay the course
in key areas such as justice the fight
against corruption organized crime media
freedom and economic reforms
but in the meantime the european union
also has to deliver
and in particular the lack of a decision
for opening the negotiations
with north macedonia and albania
is jeropotizing our standing and our
leverage in the region
therefore it was very important today
throughout the course of the day
to move forward on this process to
clarify this process there is an
intensive work being done
by the commission
to
really find the key issues in
the bilateral topics between bulgaria
and north macedonia it's five plus one
issue and to make sure that we get it
into a road map so that there's a very
practical step forwards to solve
problems
we've been discussing in at the summit
that
the dialogue
the willingness to solve problems and
the capability to address difficult and
problematic issue is the core of what
the european union is all about if you
look at our more than 70 years of
history that's how we build the european
union and therefore i'm very confident
that we are able to solve these issues
important is also the practical ground
work on the ground
for example if we look at overcoming the
pandemic
we have provided 3.3 billion euros to
the region to address the emergency of
the crisis
we've donated 2.9 million doses of
vaccines
and we have proven
that we were the western balkans most
reliable partner in this crisis and we
will continue being the closest partners
in years and decades to come
and as i've said we've put 9 billion
euros on the table for the economic and
investment plan this could be a game
changer
to give you very practical examples for
example to have
serbia help improve the waste water
management so that the danube can be
clean right down to the black sea
or we discussed with bosnian-herzegovina
the fact that they want to phase out its
coal-powered power plants
and replace them by clean alternatives
this could be part
of the investment or improvement to rail
and road connections across the region
thus also linking better greece to the
rest of the european union just to name
a few of the topics
we prepared an action plan for the
western balkan green agenda
we are launching an innovation agenda to
help promote innovation in the area and
we agreed on a road to reduce roaming
charges between the european union and
the western balkans finally
last week's agreement
between kosovo and serbia
on the tensions over the license plate
an agreement that was facilitated by the
european union was an excellent message
also to the region
that it is possible
with sitting down at the negotiation
table we're showing the willingness to
find solution that even in very
difficult situations we are able to find
those solutions and to move forward
and i think if we look at our
declaration today it is a very clear
statement
that our commitment to enlargement
is the very first in the very first
paragraph that shows our willingness
here to move forward thank you
thank you madam president
mr prime minister please
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
perspective
we'll take a few questions first in the
room here martin dunai from the
financial times please
martin
please come to the stand
you need a microphone
yes thank you uh martin tonight from the
finish times
um
uh prime minister janza touched upon
this i wanted to ask that uh the date
that 2030 rainy day indeed is
conspicuously missing uh from this
declaration
um i understand that um
you have this urgency
to act in in in the interest of
enlargement but uh
what is your sense what kind of
credibility does this have it's it's a
it's a long declaration
but um
what kind of actual specific hope can
this give to the citizens of the region
to to actually be committed to their
forms on their side
to complete the process and
i was going to limit myself to this but
the energy prices being where they are
today
gas prices at a record level i have to
ask about that too
um
the emissions trading system also
obviously is affected so you know energy
market reform seems
inevitable
um
a lot of leaders are really expecting
the eu to to step up and act decisively
on this uh what do you think uh
the european union can do uh either on
the commission or the council level
thank you very much
first first frustration i can guarantee
you that the talks
we had this morning and this afternoon
were very useful because
we feel the importance to act and that's
why we've clarified what are the common
priorities and i've explained at the
beginning
values reforms investment and also the
important topic of disputes and we were
very active the last hour the last days
in order to help to provide support to
facilitate all the efforts that are
needed in order to make progress but
there is something very interesting
yesterday we had this informal dinner on
the geopolitical role of the eu and
today we had this western balkans summit
these concrete examples it shows if we
want to be
more efficient if we want to be more
decisive that we need also to take into
account the situation in this region and
to see how we can deliver more concrete
results and you are right this is a long
declaration because this is a
declaration with a lot of concrete
commitments concrete engagements and now
we will implement with our partners we
have our homework and they have their
homework and will cooperate with
coordinate point one point two the
energy price it's an especially
situation of gas i had the opportunity
last week to communicate on this topic
and to explain that i intend it after
consultation with the member states to
put this topic on the agenda for the
next european council in brussels on
21st and 27th of october and yesterday
uh two members of the european transit
took the floor in order to to open uh
the discussions on this topic knowing
that what we want this is a serious
preparation in order to be to be able
during the next european council to give
some orientations and we will count on
the on the support the important support
by the commission because it's also not
a secret and probably also i will say
more about that but the commission
intends to publish a communication which
will be the foundation the basis in
order to make sure that all the leaders
will have the same level of
understanding the same starting point
the same level of information and so we
can make progress together in order to
address this important this important
question at the national level because
the energy mix is a national
responsibility of the member states but
maybe maybe and probably this is what i
hope there is also a political space in
order to to to to try to follow a more
common european approach on this
important topic
yes
um
so uh to your first question what makes
you
my words so confident
for the western balkan
enlargement process two things of today
first of all listening to the
debate and the comments of the leaders
a vast majority
has expressed their support
um for the enlargement process mainly
also looking at now stepping forward
with albania and north macedonia
even the more skeptical ones and this is
a very clear sign i'm aware of the fact
that we still have to solve the issues
bilateral issues between bulgaria and
north macedonia here i'm confident that
we will find solutions but the strong
support overall
was important and my second point is the
fact that we are investing 30 billion
euros in the region speaks for itself
we're deeply convinced that this is for
not only for the benefit of the western
balkan but also for the benefit of the
european union and that it will smoothen
the part a path towards enlargement what
energy is concerned
first of all
to clarify one thing
it is indeed the high energy prices
are
mainly
resulting from skyrocketing gas prices
and if you look at the renewables they
have been stable in the price and
they've dropped over the last years in
the price so it's very clear that our
future
is the renewables and certainly not over
time gas also all
also because of the dependency we have
with gas 90 percent of the gas we use is
being imported so it's very clear
where the future for us lies indeed in
the short term it's mostly national
tasks to fulfill we will have a
communication with the commission next
wednesday at the college of the
commissioners in preparation then for
the structured debate uh in the council
so that we look at the national measures
that are possible but that we also look
at medium and long-term possible action
on the european level
uh
uh
continental
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you next question is for helena
milinkovic
from the national radio
and tv here in slovenia please helena
um
uh
foreign
emotionally in charge
thank you next question is for lea
marshall agency
now just just uh a few a few points i
would like to reiterate that of course
the freedom of crisis is an important
european value this is one first point
and certain point
we have put some mechanism in place in
order to to strengthen the european rule
of law in order to promote our
fundamental values you know to promote
the the the governance we had
last year when we decided on the net
european budget and the recovery fund
important tools in order to put in place
a new mechanism this mechanism will be
fully operational very soon and it shows
the importance for the european council
i'm certain also for the commission
israel of the treaties to make sure that
the existing mechanism and the future
mechanism that will be put in place can
be used with respect with the
different opinions you know to make sure
that
the eu institutions are able
to play their role in order to promote
those fundamental values
yes what
the lack of financing of the sta is
concerned we have repeatedly expressed
our serious concerns as regards of the
lack of this financing of the civilian
press agency because this is the the
funding the ongoing funding is important
for its independence
last week vice president yurova has sent
a letter to the slovenian authority
stressing the urgency of the situation
and reminding the obligations of the
government this has recently been
confirmed by the slovenian supreme court
and i think overall it shows
once again the need for eu legislation
to protect media freedom and pluralism
via the media freedom act that i have
announced in the state of the union
because i'm deeply convinced defending
media freedom means defending our
democracy
and media companies cannot be treated
like any other business because their
independence is so crucial for um for
the democracies and
the reporting behind it
i wanted to at one
point if i may to the energy topic i
think it is important that we keep in
mind
that the spike of energy prices is a
global phenomenon it's not limited to
the european union it's a global
phenomenon
we should also keep in mind that last
year because of the pandemic
the energy prices have been
much lower than normally so right now
this is also a rebound because of the
picking up of the economy and thus we
have to treat the short-term effects but
over the long term we also have to deal
with the fact that the storage at the
moment being is limited so it's also a
question of storage for the european
union
thank you madam president we have
leo marshall agency rob
financier
[Music]
excuse me we'll take another question
here b
please let us conduct this
press conference in an orderly fashion
in question
strategic escape
[Music]
[Music]
um
yes indeed
in the discussion yesterday it was very
interesting to see
that we should
also speak about our strength
we are the world's biggest trading bloc
we are front runners
if you look at the answer how to fight
climate change we are setting norms and
standards in the digital world
through our human centric legislation
and we are the region that has shipped
the most doses of a vaccine
to the neighborhood
we have exported more than 800 million
doses of vaccines
to more than 130 countries
not to speak of the
on top 500 million
doses of vaccines that have been pledged
as donation
so sometimes it's also good to recall uh
what we are doing
and
what the relation with the united states
is concerned i had a phone call with
president president biden on monday
evening
and
it was reaffirming
for example our vaccine partnership
between the european union and the
united states
to vaccinate the world
it's not only the export it's not only
the donation but it's also creating
manufacturing hubs
in different regions than the highly
industrialized countries
it was about joining forces before cup
26
to have a strong answer to
the problems of climate change mainly
also to join forces on climate finance
for the developing countries
it was also about the trade and
technology council that took place for
the first time and was a big success and
a
big step forward in this common agenda
and of course we discussed in this phone
call the topic of defense in the light
of the issues around orcas
and here i think it is important
also yesterday evening in the discussion
very clear confirmation
nato is the strongest military alliance
in the world and the european union will
never be a military alliance
but there are scenarios where
we do not see nato
but it might be necessary for the
european union
to be able to act
and therefore it is a lot about
improving our capabilities as european
union is also a question of
interoperability
and the question of strengthening our
industrial basis
and to adapt our capabilities to the new
threats and here it's mainly the cyber
topic
so what is also clear all these efforts
that we are pursuing now and building
towards the defence summit next year
are complementary to nato
but they give the european union the
capability to act if the political will
is there to engage
thank you prime minister we'll take a
question remotely
um
[Music]
[Music]
taiwan a second question if i made to
president van der lyon on the issue of
enlargement i'm sure you have
read or heard about an article by
politico
on your uh commissioner for enlargement
um
who allegedly pushed for uh serbia in
the process and
is putting a rule of law and human
rights issue under the carpet
um i'm wondering if you have any
reaction on that
and if commissioner
vareli has your
confidence full confidence thank you
um yes the question that was for me
so
all commissioners of
the college of commissioners have my
full confidence
serbia has come a long way but of course
there's still a lot to do also on the
issue of rule of law
this was also content of my talks with
president wutschich and prime minister
bernabej
last week in serbia itself
and of course
they acknowledge that there's still work
to do
and as you know in a regular process the
services and
the director generals
the dgs of the commission with their
experts with a lot of experience since
years not to say decades
are reporting on a regular basis on the
progress of the individual
country that is in an accession process
we'll take one last question remotely
angela mauro angela are still with us
yes
yes thank you
good afternoon to everybody i have two
quick questions for the three presidents
uh the first one is uh
do you think uh uh
the russian authorities are responsible
uh for the rising of
energy pricing
prices as gas problem is cutting the
deliveries
the exports
outside russia and the second question
is maybe it's more for the president of
the commission
as as far as i understand there is no
agreement among member states on the
idea of common storage can we assume
that in the next in the communication
you will be presenting next week uh this
idea will be okay will be maybe taken
into consideration but we will wait the
debate uh
at the european council in october uh in
two weeks time and so the communication
will have more mostly national
measures or suggestions for national
measures thank you
yeah on the first on the first question
um i would like to be to be careful
because uh we would like to to assess
what's the exact situation and based on
the the first
elements uh we think that there are
different elements uh that are playing a
role and that are influencing the price
of gas certainly the launch winter in
some in some regions uh a certain point
the increase of the demands of gas uh in
china the southern element some
technical problems in norway and
probably also in russia and also one of
the elements that you have mentioned the
level the level of production of gas in
russia this is probably one of those
elements but we need to have a look at
the global picture and that's why we
thought based on the first stalls we had
yesterday evening this is good to
prepare very well this debate with the
expertise of the commission it will be
provided to the to the member states and
so we will have a clear picture and
based on a clear picture i hope we'll be
able to see what can be done at the
national level and this will be the
responsibility of the membership to act
at the national level and we'll see also
if it's possible and if it is
appropriate to act at the european level
based on the worked the work that will
be prepared by the commission yeah very
briefly on that too
we are preparing now the communication
and of course the question of storage
will be part of the communication but
detailed old out next week and what the
first part of your question is concerned
indeed we need to have the full numbers
and the full picture the one thing i
observe is that norway one of our
suppliers is now stepping up and
increasing the supply and i think this
is a very good example others could
follow
thank you
to all
all language versions of the berdo
declaration are online now thank you for
joining us and see you soon